und über die aktuelle Situation in der
Ukraine kann ich nun sprechen mit
Norbert Norbert Hahn der uns aus Kiew
zugeschaltet ist guten Morgen Herr Hahn
guten Morgen ja der Rückzug der Russen
aus der Stadt Carson vorgestern der ist
ja ungewöhnlicherweise von den Russen
vorher quasi angekündigt worden er ist
ja scheinbar jetzt im Gange was können
sie uns berichten wie ist die aktuelle
Situation dort
ja wir wissen natürlich nicht so sehr
viel nachprüfbares auch der Region wir
können nicht in die Region fahren die
journalistischen Kollegen die anderen
können das auch nicht es wird gekämpft
da gerade
schon selbst die Stadt so weit ich weiß
sind die ukrainischen Truppen da noch
nicht eingerückt es geht immer noch um
die Region und in der Region das haben
wir am Beitrag auch gerade schon gesehen
sind mindestens 41 Ortschaften schon
wieder eingenommen worden von der
ukrainischen Armee wahrscheinlich sind
sie jetzt schon mehr als sie diese Zahl
41 ist von gestern Abend von Präsidenten
selenski der hat das gesagt der sprach
davon dass man über mehrere Achsen
sieben Kilometer vorgerückt sei aber ich
kann mir vorstellen dass das jetzt in
diesem Moment wo wir miteinander
sprechen schon schon mehr ist also die
ukrainische Armee setzt nach es gibt
jetzt erste Berichte dass ukrainische
Truppen offenbar den Fluss nepro
überschritten hätten was würde das
Besondere bedeuten was das mutmaßliche
vor in der Ukraine angeht
also ich habe nicht gehört dass die
Ukraine den Fluss überschritten hätten
also bislang ging es immer nur um die
Russen die vor der vorrückenden
ukrainischen Armee ausweichen und auf
den auf die östliche nepro Seite um dort
eben die mittlerweile wohl befestigten
Stellungen einzunehmen also im Moment
ist es so dass die dass die russische
Armee über den nepro vom Westen auf die
auf die östliche Seite des nipro flieht
muss man sagen und dabei heftig
beschossen wird von der ukrainischen
Armee von Artillerie von den
heimersystemen die die ukrainische Armee
von den USA erhalten hat diesen mehrfach
Raketenwerfern also der Abzug der
russischen Armee ist an sich für für
Russland für die für die Militärkomplex
durchaus eine eine große Gefahr jetzt
noch mal ich denke so wie es aussieht
gibt es da auf russischer Seite viele
Opfer ja es ist ja wohl ein großer
Erfolg militärtechnisch gesehen bei
allen Opfern trotzdem für die Ukraine
Herr Hahn die fallen denn ob dieses
Erfolges die Reaktion in Kiew aus
also ich würde sagen zweigeteilt gerade
wenn man hier mit den Menschen spricht
dann merkt man dass die natürlich
glücklich sind dass die ukrainische
Armee vorrückt ansonsten teilt man die
Skepsis mit der Regierung und auch mit
dem Militär man möchte sich nicht zu
früh freuen man freut sich natürlich
über die Ankündigung aber man möchte
Taten sehen und man möchte natürlich
auch dass es auf eigener Seite nicht
noch viele Opfer gibt und das ist auch
so ein bisschen der der Hintergrund der
vorsichtigen
Äußerungen von Präsident selenski man
möchte nicht dass die eigenen Truppen in
Sprengfallen laufenden Minenfelder
laufen und deswegen sagt man wir gehen
langsam vor
ja das ist verständlich zumal aus den
USA die Meldung kommt die besagt dass
amerikanische Militärs schätzen das
hunderttausend Menschen auf weitaus auf
jeder Seite auf Seite der Russen aber
auch auf der Seite der Ukraine bisher
gestorben sind eine wie ich finde
ungeheure Zahl Erhan schaue mir zum
Schluss noch auf die großstadtrativ die
ja seit dem 24 Februar quasi bombardiert
und beschossen worden ist oder
vielleicht auch noch wird Stichwort
Luftabwehr die ja auch aus den Westen in
Ländern auch aus Deutschland geliefert
worden ist hat das die Situation in
Krake in krakev oder möglicherweise auch
in anderen großen Städten denn jetzt
verbessert was den Schutz angeht
ja das hat sie ganz sicher ich wir
können da keine Statistiken geben weil
das ukrainische Militär über sowas
eigentlich nie etwas sagt aber ich denke
es ist zum Greifen dass die Luftabwehr
die modernen Systeme die da Westen
geliefert hat eben auch Deutschland dass
das was gebracht hat das ist das ist
ganz klar ja und man hofft auf mehr die
USA haben in den vergangenen Tagen ja
noch mal wieder ein Hilfspaket zugesagt
und da sind auch wieder
Luftabwehrsysteme drin Hawk
abwehrraketenabwehrsysteme also ich
denke dass ich denke es wirkt und die
Ukraine will mehr denn es ist ja völlig
offen wie lange dieser Krieg noch dauert
aber dann schnelles Ende jedenfalls
glaubt hier keiner Luftabwehr hilft was
ist ansonsten nötig der Winter hält
jetzt ja auch Einzug in der kleine was
brauchen die Menschen am dringendsten
ja das macht hier vielen Menschen
tatsächlich Sorgen auf der einen Seite
auf der anderen Seite muss man auch
sagen viele können wenig können wir
eigentlich wenig tun wenn man an
Eigenheim hat dann kann man sich noch
was einfallen lassen ich habe gestern
hier mit einem Mann gesprochen der
gesagt hat ich habe eine große Terrasse
da der Mauer ich zu um einfach um um die
Wärme zu halten aber das das sind
natürlich Einzelfälle im Großen und
Ganzen viele Leben in in
Etagenwohnungen gerade hier in den
größeren Städten wie Kiew da kann man
eigentlich wenig machen und das Problem
ist nach wie vor es gibt oftmals über
mehrere Stunden am Tag kein Wasser es
gibt über mehrere Stunden auch keine
Elektrizität das ist in der Taten
Problem die Menschen können nur sehr
bescheiden etwas tun zum Beispiel ihre
ihre
Taschenlampen bereithalten oder ihre
powerbanks aufladen damit Sie auch in
der Nacht erreichbar sind wenn was
passiert viel machen kann man nicht der
Winter könnte tatsächlich hart werden
neue Herausforderungen bringen ja man
wird das einfach sehen müssen die
Energiekonsum wird steigen und man kann
nur hoffen dass die
elektrizitätsgesellschaften in Kiew hier
und anderswo in der Lage sind die
Leitung zu reparieren und die
Energieversorgung wieder auf gute Beine
zu stellen Norbert Hahn war das aus Kiew
ich sage vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit und
danke für diese Erläuterungen